COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some sports fans fix
their caching performance.
Will we hit a performance
buzzer beater?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Geeky Sports is
a website devoted
to the latest and greatest
regarding your favorite sci-fi
fantasy-based sports.
Yes, they even have coverage
of that wizard-based broomstick
soccer game with the
flying locust thing
that people try to catch.
Anyhow, their engineering
team reached out
after they deployed a new
CDN and thumbnailing service,
only to see a massive
"cache fill" cost show up
on their cloud bill.
Yet no performance improvement's
showing up for their customers.
Now, this all sounds
like the right setup.
So let's try to figure
out what's going on.
Firstly, to check that
the assets were actually
being cached, we took a look
at the logging information
for the load balancer
in the cloud console.
Each request that's
logged will have
information detailing if
it properly had a cache hit
or not.
For example, we can see that
the first request resulted
in a lookup, a
failure, and a fill.
Meanwhile, our second
request to the same resource
results in just a cache hit.
Looking back at the
logs for Geeky Sports,
we can see that
the number of cache
hit entries is really low for
the traffic during the day.
So it seems that the requests
were getting cached but not
being re-used by future
requests, hence the high cache
fill bill.
Now, let's think about
this for a second.
At their core, CDNs are really
just massively distributed
hash tables.
When a request
comes into the CDN,
it converts the URI of that
request to a cache key.
If that key matches anything
that's already been cached,
then it just returns
the associated object.
Now, by default,
Google Cloud CDN
uses the complete request
URI as the cache key,
which means if you change
the protocol, like moving
from HTTP to HTTPS, you're
not going to get a cache hit.
And likewise, if the
query string is different,
you won't get a match either.
And that last one seems
to be the important one.
Looking back at
the logged request,
Geeky Sports is passing the
user token as a URL param, which
means that each user
was causing each asset
to be cached by the CDN
individually, rather than
being shared between users.
Thankfully for
our geeky friends,
the fix is pretty
straightforward.
Using Google Cloud
CDN's custom cache keys,
we can modify how
the CDN matches
URIs for specific
assets and tell
it to ignore the query string.
Looking at the logs, we can
see that even though the user
ID is different, we got a
proper hit on the asset.
To learn more about how Geeky
Sports decreased their costs,
check out the related article
linked in the description
below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]